et puisqu'on parle de fossiles nous
allons maintenant vous présentez une
vieille connaissance laissés-pour-compte
pendant des années que l' agence de
l'environnement bien contente de
redécouvrir la géothermie premières
énergies renouvelables d'île de france
et hermes de choc paraît-il contre la
hausse des prix du pétrole et la
pollution et c'est le dossier de la
rédaction emmanuel lagarde nathalie
berthier
c'est une chaufferie pas comme les
autres en fait une immense pompe qui va
chercher la chaleur à 1800 mètres sous
terre
j'ouvre le robinet et là j'ai de l'eau
fossile et à 113 degrés c'est en fait
une aux vieilles de plusieurs millions
d'années et qui est en fait de l'eau de
mer
cette ressource du bassin parisien
maisons alfort l'utilisent depuis vingt
ans des résidences collectives à la
piscine 40% de la ville se chauffe
grâce à la géothermie l'expérience
commence en pleine crise pétrolière 1980
les forages fleurissent en région
parisienne et l'on promet même la
disparition du chauffage au fioul d'ici
dix ans l'avenir de la jeune permis
cette à l'horizon 85 deux cent cinquante
mille à trois cents à trois cents mille
logements et pour les années 90 800
mille logements
mais les maladies de jeunesse plomb de
ce développement des problèmes de
corrosion puis la chute du prix du
pétrole tu la rentabilité de la
géothermie
aujourd'hui en france seuls 150 mille
logements utilisent encore cette énergie
c'est 2% de la production de chaleur
nationale même s'il fait froid dehors
j'ai quand même encore maintenant ça ne
bouge pas la température ne bouge pas
face à la récente hausse du prix du
pétrole
le syndic de cet immeuble a renouvelé
son contrat de géothermie c'est
légèrement moins cher que le gaz au jour
de notre audit
le différentiel entre la géothermie et
le gaz va être de l'ordre de plus de 15%
et si le gaz continuent à augmenter ça
serait très intéressant une énergie
durable prête pour un nouveau
développement sur les opérations
existantes ont peu et voir à alimenter
d'autres immeubles donc agrandir
l'opération elle-même mais surtout ce
qui est important je pense c'est de
ressortir les dossiers de faisabilité
des années 80 qui avait été enterrée par
ce projet me choc pétrolier à l'envers
entre lui même et qui aujourd'hui
permettrait de développer des opérations
nouvelles objectif pour l'ile-de-france
chauffer 130 mille logements
supplémentaires dans 15 ans